Dans mon jardin, il y a aussi des tulipes. Cette fleur est originaire d'Iran et d'Afghanistan.
Au début du 16e siècle, elle ne pousse que dans les jardins du sultan Soliman le Magnifique à Istanbul .
Une fois posé sur leur tête,
le bandeau des dignitaires ottomans
ressemblait tellement à cette fleur qu'il
en prit le nom : "tulipan" qui va donner turbans.
Bien qu'il ne le fait jamais et qu'il les garde pour lui,
le sultan fini par donner un bulbe à un botaniste
des Pays-bas qui le multiple.
A Amsterdam, cette fleur si rare prend beaucoup de
valeur : un bulbe pouvait valoir le prix d'une maison !
1, 2, 3, 4, 5... Vous imaginez la fortune !
Allez à demain et surtout n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...